TEAM UNDERSCORES THE BREADTH OF
THE INVESTIGATION AND ITS
ATTEMPTS TO TIE ANY AND ALL
THINGS RUSSIA INTO THIS PROBE.
BRITISH DETECTIVES BELIEVE THE
FORMER KREMLIN SPY AND HIS
DAUGHTER WHO WERE POISONED
EARLIER THIS MONTH IN ENGLAND
CAME INTO CONTACT WITH A
SUBSTANCE ON THE FRONT DOOR OF
THEIR HOME.
AS MORE COUNTRIES EXPEL RUSSIAN
DIPLOMATS BECAUSE OF THIS
INCIDENT, THE RUSSIANS ARE
FIGHTING BACK TONIGHT.
THEY INSIST BRITISH AGENTS ARE
BEHIND THE ATTACK IN AN EFFORT
TO FRAME RUSSIA.
GILLIAN TURNER TALKS TO THE
BRITISH AMBASSADOR ABOUT THE
LATEST DEVELOPMENTS.
>> WE KNEW THE RUSSIANS DID IT.
NATO KNOWS THE RUSSIANS STATED.
THE UNITED STATES ADMINISTRATION
KNOWS THE RUSSIANS DID IT.
>> DESPITE WHAT THE AMBASSADOR
CALLED OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE,
RUSSIA DENIES POISONING A FORMER
SPY.
THE KREMLIN IS TURNING THE STORY
ON ITS HEAD AND ACCUSING THE
BRITISH GOVERNMENT OF CARRYING
OUT THE ATTACKS THEMSELVES.
POINTING THE BLAME AT BRITISH
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES.
"IT'S CONVINCING EVIDENCE TO THE
CONTRARY IS NOT PRESENTED TO THE
RUSSIAN SIDE.
WE WILL CONSIDER WE ARE DEALING
WITH AN ATTEMPT ON THE LIVES OF
OUR CITIZENS AS A RESULT OF A
MASSIVE POLITICAL PROVOCATION."
ANY FOX NEWS EXCLUSIVE, THE
BRITISH AMBASSADOR INSIST THESE
RUSSIAN ACCUSATIONS AREN'T
WORTHY OF RESPONSE.
>> THEY HAVE A TRACK RECORD OF
USING NERVE AGENTS AND A TRACK
RECORD OF STATE-SPONSORED
ASSASSINATIONS.
THERE'S NO QUESTION IN OUR MINDS
THERE'S NO QUESTION IN OUR MIND
MINDS.
WE HAVE PUT OUT EVERYTHING WE
NEED TO TO DEMONSTRATE OUR
CONVICTION THAT THE RUSSIANS ARE
RESPONSIBLE.
>> THE STATE DEPARTMENT AGREES.
>> RUSSIA ALWAYS DENIES
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ITS BEHAVIOR
BUT WE HAVE PROOF.
THE BRITS HAVE PROOF.
>> THERE IS MOUNTING CONSENSUS
AMONG THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY THAT THE RUSSIANS
LATEST MOVE VIOLATES THE SACRED
RULES OF NATIONAL SOVEREIGNTY
AND THEY SHOULD FACE
CONSEQUENCES.
MORE THAN 25 NATIONS HAVE
ALREADY FOLLOWED THE U.S. LEAD
AND FORCED OUT RUSSIAN DIPLOMATS
IN A SHOW OF SOLIDARITY.
BUT IT'S THE SUPPORT AND
FRIENDSHIP OF THE U.S. AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT MEANS THE
MOST TO BRITAIN.
>> THIS IS A GREAT DEMONSTRATION
OF THE STRENGTH OF THE
RELATIONSHIP AND WE ARE
ENORMOUSLY APPRECIATIVE OF WHAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE, THE
DECISIVENESS AND STRENGTH HE
SHOWED.
>> THE BRITISH AMBASSADOR
INSISTS THE DRAMA WILL ONLY
SERVE TO STRENGTHEN THE SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN BRITAIN AND
THE UNITED STATES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL NEED ALL
THE SUPPORT HE CAN MUSTER SHOULD
HE AGREE TO A MEETING WITH PUTIN
IN THE SPRING, SOMETHING THE